N."
INVESTIGATINY 6th
E  B
EMITTEE AR THE BJUSTACT,ININCLU.
HERE WITH ME NOW IS A MEF
E h MM
REPUBLICAN ADAM R OF ICONGRESSMR
KR NCULARLY ON
FAE ICALLYESAB
SHE SAID EVERYBODY HAS B
SHE ALSO PUT INTQU IBILITSIDY
THIS IS NOT -- ID WITH
ISTI NOEM I SIONBO
SERVEDH.
KRISOERVED WITH, YOU KNOW, WAS .
ABE TICA AT IME WO WOULD
ANY
RUNNIOR
PRESEN VICE PRT.
SHSCARED TO DEAT THE
FOR HER TO CAL QIO YOU , A OOD
THAT DONALD TRUMBON AN
IBY AMEVERY DAY BY WHAT THIS I Y
>> THERE- I DON'NE T
TE TWO
ON THIS COMMITRE ONE OTHLY.
VERY TOUGH ION FIGHT IN.D OF O
INEEK. OIS NOT I
BEUS P
TRUMP.AVE SERIOUS QUESTIONS ABO
THE 2020ION.
SMALL PORTION OFERN RE
>> THERE IFRAUD HAPPENMING
E MY OATH
OF OE.IF ,  TO VOTE F
SOME EAGE.
ADTION
AR-OLD SON WOULDLIKE.U F ARMPITN
>>K,
HOW  I WAY.EYEE
WITH HER POSITION ONR,SHSTF HER
CONSTITUTE YEPND SAI
AT ON
ISSUES.ESE CO DEMOCRACY IKEECWHA
SHOULD BE.HAT EVERY ELSHOULD BE.
OPPONENT WAS AIG SUPPORTER OF L
THEIR CONSTITUENTS.
THISD INTO - I MEAN, I HONESTLY
THINK THE POLISTS A D
HAVE GOT TD DEMAND FAR BETTER B
LIKE LIZNEY, A VAL FOCUSED PSOGD
WITH HER PICS, OF ,
COPI 10%F THE TRY ORTRICT OFOM
PRIMARY AND MAKE A DECISION.
MARY MILLER BEY DAS RE IN ILLINW
TO CHANGE.LOOK, LI BLESS, SH
MAKING A STAND
I THINK SH I LESSON TO EVERY
YO, LET'S TURNO E TESTIMON M FO
HAE CAR ON DN DEPUTYFF TONY NATL
ID UP TO T NOW. THin
THE ESD UP TO TH VEHICLE TO ARI,
SIR, YOU NEED
WE'RE GOING BACK TO
HAND TO LUNGE TOWARDS BOBBY >>
GORNG TO
AND SOMET CES
ARDISPUTG THE ACCOUNT.
OTTHS
WHAT THEY.S E TRYING TDISCREDII
WHY DIE PU THIS,THATAND
THRST OBTAEVIDENCEO SAY
T LET DON' IN
MEE  IS
THIS IS WHAT SHERD.
AT NO POINT SHE SAY SHE WAS
HEH THE PRESIDENT  HAPPEN.HAVEO
SOS  THE . Y'RAND THIS
IS TYPICAL WORLD, THAT
NOBODY HAS ARGUED, NOBODY HAS TT
WANT TO GO TO THE CAPITOL.DY HAE
THERE WERE GUNEY'RE TRYING TO A
HAVEO Y. CHSTIFIED UNDER TH.
WE FIND HER
TSO CASTARESD ALSO  UNDER OATH.
T THROUGH S SOURCES,  UNQUOTEANC
HUTCHINSON'S TESTIMONY, HAVE NEW
WITNESSES COMEOR
UP?.
CASSIDY. DON'T W OTHE T
EVERY DAYEVERY Y EORI
COME FORWARD AND SAYDN'T TI KNE
DO SEES  H
BUT, YEAH, I MEAN,OOK, S
THE COMMTHT  N ONE OF US ON
SHE DOESN'T WANT
A EN THAT SOMEONE  K AND MOST L
STORIES YOU